[Musica]
avete mai pensato veramente quello che
stavate stazione in quel momento cioè
tipo io adesso non sono qui sul palco e
e farlo e adesso ho imparato gli ultimi
due anni a vivere il momento
per un discorso sportivo per un discorso
personale io sono l'esame perilli
sparo per la repubblica di san marino la
mia passione più lavoro e lo faccio da
19 anni sono mamma di un bimbo di 7 anni
e mezzo
e la una vita e sparare e appunto fare
la mamma ho vinto 19 medaglie
internazionali
queste ultime due sono la ventesimo e
ventunesimo
e adesso vi racconto un po come come
inseguito questo sogno come sono
riuscita a raggiungerlo è partito tutto
da delle olimpiadi di londra avevo 24
anni
mi qualifico per le olimpiadi
mai fatta atleta professionista quindi
dal gennaio del 2012 prof all atleta
professionista
e arriva alle olimpiadi con una
spensieratezza
incredibile nel senso che mi dice ok
adesso vado li eleggono teme le vivo che
no stop anche porta bandiera
lui il vero momento ed era bellissimo
perché era un sogno realizzato e mai
pedana così forse proprio con con
quell'aria tranquillo moto dire va bene
devo dimostrarti da nessuno vengo qui me
la gioco mi diverto e quindi iniziò a
sparare i piattelli
tranquilla finito l'italiana vice con
dei record assurdi mi giro e guardo
dalla magna vedo il mio nome
tra le prime tre tra le prime quattro
scusate e dico dio
oddio può essere medaglia cioè no un
attimo e lì è crollato tutto il mondo io
non ero più lì in quel momento io non mi
stanno più vivendo
l'alessandra alle olimpiadi di londra in
quel momento erano l'esame che stava già
pensando al futuro a quello che poteva
succedere quindi pizzolano medaglia
olimpica
l'uno con l'altro il mondo perché
purtroppo ho imparato col tempo che se
viviamo nel futuro il presente
cade aperte e così è stato portato un
quarto posto sembra
sembrano dire caro non è il quarto posto
alle olimpiadi
sì ma è stato il mio incubo il mio
incubo peggiore fino fino al 29 luglio
del 2021 e
quello made in italy nel senso che
comunque ho partecipato anche rio de
janeiro video genero si incrementano la
carta olimpica per poterci andare
un'olimpiade terrifica punto è perché le
aspettative erano tantissime e
aspettative anche mie personali perché
dunque volevano rivincere sembrava
ancora non era partita da casa sembrava
che sta medaglia la viabilità e invece
no
no anzi è stato lui ed è
terrificante
tornata a casa
fece un sacco di cambiamenti e poi mi
ritrovai nel 2000 e fine 2018 a parlare
con la mia psicologa e mi disse al è
arrivato il momento che queste galli
diamo una svolta dobbiamo non solo
quelle gare anche nella vita personale
no bisogna viverci momento adesso il che
qui e ora adesso non è né domani né
stato ieri e adesso
quindi dobbiamo cambiare un prodotto e
da lì abbiamo iniziato intraprende un
percorso che era semplice lavare i
piatti cioè mentre io ero lì a lavare i
piatti dovevo pensare a quello che stavo
facendo ed era durissima cioè all'inizio
ma com'è possibile
dieci minuti ci metterà i piatti eppure
la testa va dunque invece che stai lì
quindi mi è stato così da sempre sulla
vari piatti a guidare la macchina che
anche mentre guidi io sono spesso in
giro per l'italia e in giro per il mondo
mentre guido sono le ricche perso a
chissà quali 10 sto facendo che invece
adesso ho imparato a cui dare inizio
ad avere sensazioni diverse
e queste cose abbiamo invitato metterle
ancora più in pratica angeli pedana
quindi mentre io sono in pedana perso
esattamente a quello che sto facendo
però un conto è farlo per 20 25 minuti
in quote fallo tutta la giornata tutti i
giorni per semantici una donna come
faccio a farlo così per sempre non è
semplice rimanere sempre qui mi piace
molto fantasticare andare avanti o
pensare al passato ma non è così cioè
momento è adesso
quindi così abbiamo iniziato questo
percorso e vedevamo che funziona cioè
anche nelle gare legali venivano prima
di partecipare a tokyo le cose venivano
che era una cosa fluida sera stavo bene
che vedevo anche il rapporto con mio
figlio comunque era diverso perché non
dovevo pensare oddio aspetta cosa devo
fare domani con mai poi devo darle no e
adesso adesso siamo qui sul divano e poi
quello dobbiamo fare domani ci pensiamo
a domani quando mi sveglio
enit e sono arrivata al tokyo partenza
per tokyo prima della partenza per tokyo
però
saranno infatti un tipo mantra nel senso
che andiamo a viversi la gara di tokyo
come se fosse una gara normale come se
fosse una gara come tutte le altre
diavoli ci spariamo un piattello a volte
poi vedremo come va a finire
ci pensavo alla fine ci pensiamo l'avevo
dichiarato ai giornali questa cosa mi
era stata anche un po
avevano tempo riso alle olimpiadi come
fai a dire vado lì e che sarà gara con
un'altra invece non è una gara comunale
emilio ambiente tanto della testa c'è
ancora adesso se si pensi più caldo
parola fine vero è una cartonato fatto
gare che c'erano molte più donne quindi
cioè riscontrato in molte più persone
invece eravamo solo 24 sostanzialmente
le vediamo che però ero lì
enit e quindi io sono partita per tokyo
e lì sono vissuta veramente un giorno
alla volta di una serenità io dovevo
solo pensare a sparare andare a dormire
e mangiare in palestra nient'altro non
aveva altri pensieri ero lì viveva
momento mi viveva le sensazioni
camminava lentamente tra la pena
dall'altra era aveva rallentato tutto
perché mi volevo vivere al massimo
quelle sensazione che io non sapevo come
sarebbe la patina perché non ci pensavo
non ci volevo pensarli volevo vivere
quell'istante proprio proprio a 360
gradi non lo volevo vivere ed è stato
fantastico
cioè io quando ho realizzato il sogno è
stato il momento esatto più messo piede
sul gradino che ho detto questa è mia e
me la sono presa mela sono mela sono
vissuta principio 60 gradi in di tendoni
il momento ovviamente avevamo un
aggregati è arrivata poi la seconda
medaglia è anche assurdo perché
veramente ci siamo
non è cambiato nulla se sai quando vince
la medaglia non
diceva adesso è appoggiata una medaglia
della saprese invece nome abbiamo chiuso
un portone siamo tornati e comunque
eravamo di nuovo lì in pedana con la
stanchezza dopo lo show vinto la
medaglia hanno dormito tutta la notte
però euro di nuovo lì volevo volevo di
nuovo vivermi quell'emozione perché
comunque
miller o lavorata cercata tanti notti in
bianco il discorso da un discorso
coronavirus ne avevamo passati tutti i
colori mi ero allenata in casa con tre
quarantenne contro il muro bianco di
casa perché volevano usare quel sogno lo
volevo a tutti i costi volevo
volevo portarmi a casa ste medaglie e a
molte volte
visto mi chiedevo insomma se se se
l'avrei fatto di pensare di pc2
[Musica]
quindi